l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi portant en
mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi
la parole est à Monsieur Marc Ferracci
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales cherchent collègue c'est avec
une vive satisfaction que je vous
présente aujourd'hui les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi portant en mesure
d'urgence relative au fonctionnement du
marché du travail en vue du plein emploi
je me félicite que l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat soit parvenue à travailler
ensemble dans un esprit de compromis ce
texte rappelons-le devait en effet être
examiné dans les meilleurs délais afin
d'éviter un vide juridique préjudiciable
à des millions de demandeurs d'emploi
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
je veux ici souligner la qualité des
échanges avec les équipes du
gouvernement et la co-construction dont
tout le monde a réussi à faire preuve
en préambule je tiens à rappeler
l'objectif qui nous réunit ici
aujourd'hui qui a été évoqué à maintes
reprises par le Président de la
République cette objectif c'est le plein
emploi ce projet de loi constitue une
première brique dans la stratégie de
long terme du gouvernement et de la
majorité pour permettre un maximum de
nos concitoyens d'accéder à un emploi
stable et de qualité le Parlement c'est
pleinement saisi de ce texte et député
comme sénateur en considérablement
enrichi faisant passer de 5 à 14 le
nombre d'articles au cours de la navette
l'article premier du projet de loi qui
en justifié le caractère urgent va
permettre au gouvernement de préserver
le fonctionnement de l'assurance chômage
pendant une période transitoire durant
laquelle une phase de concertation puis
de négociation sur ses règles de
gouvernance s'ouvrira avec les
partenaires sociaux la méthode
poursuivie par le gouvernement est
désormais inscrite clairement dans la
loi ainsi que les thèmes de discussion
qui devront être proposés aux
partenaires sociaux au terme de
l'article premier bis à a la possibilité
de moduler les règles de l'assurance
chômage en fonction d'indicateurs
conjoncturel et désormais inscrite dans
la loi faculté pourra se saisir le
gouvernement après que la concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux aura eu
lieu sur la prorogation des règles
actuellement en vigueur c'est ce même
article introduit par le Sénat qui
prévoit de nouvelles dispositions
incitant les bénéficiaires d'un contrat
court à accepter le CDI qui leur est
proposé sous peine de se voir privé
d'indemnités après deux refus dans les
12 mois
si le phénomène du refus de CDI est bien
réel la majorité présidentielle a eu
l'occasion au cours des discussions avec
nos collègues sénateurs de rappeler ces
doutes quant à l'efficacité de cette
mesure dans un esprit de compromis
celle-ci a néanmoins été retenue mais
elle devra faire l'objet d'une
évaluation rigoureuse
je me félicite par ailleurs que ce
projet de loi Vienne conforter le
dispositif de bonus malus sur les
contributions patronales grâce à son
article 2 qui le rend plus
compréhensible et donc plus acceptable
pour les entreprises celle-ci pourront
désormais connaître la liste des
salariés justifiant leur taux de
séparation afin de mieux en comprendre
les fondements après arrogation du
dispositif jusqu'à l'été 2024 permettra
d'en mesurer les effets avant des
envisager d'éventuelles modifications
outre des articles plus techniques
concernant les élections
professionnelles et l'attribution de
l'assurance chômage à certaines
catégories d'agents publics le projet de
loi contient grâce au travail
parlementaire de nouveaux dispositifs
visant à assurer le bon fonctionnement
du marché du travail en cette période de
fortes tensions dans de nombreux
secteurs il en va ainsi des nouvelles
règles visant à refuser l'indemnisation
de demandeurs d'emploi qui ne se
trouveraient pas dans une situation de
privation involontaire d'emploi à la
suite d'un abandon de poste cette
initiative portée par des députés des
groupes renaissances démocrates horizons
et les républicains répond à une réelle
difficulté remontée du terrain
afin de faire progresser l'emploi stable
il est également prévu de renforcer le
dispositif du CDI intérimaire en
permettant que les missions réalisées
dans ce cadre puis s'étendre au-delà
d'une durée de 36 mois
l'article 4 du projet de loi qui a été
considérablement enrichi par le
gouvernement et les parlementaires vice
quant à lui a créé un véritable service
public de la validation des acquis de
l'expérience cette réforme a pour
ambition de simplifier les parcours pour
atteindre l'objectif de 100.000 VAE
chaque année l'objectif initial et qui
demeure visant à valoriser l'expérience
des proches aidants le projet de loi a
résolument ouvert ce dispositif à toute
personne qui justifie d'une activité en
lien avec le contenu de la certification
visé article 5 qui n'a pas de portée
concrète pour nos concitoyens vient tout
de même satisfaire aux conditions de
l'article 38 de la Constitution en
proposant au Parlement de ratifier 20
ordonnances prise notamment durant la
crise sanitaire il s'agit là de revenir
devant le Parlement tout autant que de
sécuriser a posteriori les outils qui
ont été nécessaires durant cette période
si les derniers articles qui ont fait
l'objet d'un vote conforme de
l'assemblée du Sénat ont donc pas été
soumis à la CMP je tiens à rappeler que
sur proposition de Monsieur Valtou un
rapport sur l'offre raisonnable d'emploi
et sur proposition de Monsieur dareville
à rapport sur la conformité des offres
diffusées par Pôle Emploi seront
transmis par le gouvernement
aller vers le plein emploi cher
collègues et pour notre pays une ardente
nécessitée c'est pourquoi je vous invite
à adopter le texte
issu des travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire qui résulte d'un compromis
équilibré et riche entre les deux
assemblées je vous remercie merci
monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plan d'emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés je suis très
heureux avec Carole Grandjean d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui pour la lecture
et l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui a
débouché sur un texte de compromis
permettant un accord des représentants
des deux chambres et donc de nous
retrouver à cet instant de la procédure
je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement Monsieur le rapporteur
pour la qualité des travaux conduit en
sa qualité mais aussi pour la qualité du
dialogue que nous avons pu avoir pour
avancer trouver des solutions parfois
techniques à des sujets extrêmement
politiques et au même titre que Monsieur
rapporteur je souhaite remercier
l'ensemble des orateurs des groupes pour
leur participation et ses travaux et
plus particulièrement celles et ceux qui
ont permis d'aboutir à ce compromis le
gouvernement souhaité par cette loi
proroger et donc garantir la mise en
oeuvre de l'indemnisation des demandeurs
d'emploi à partir du 1er novembre 2022
c'est chose faite jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2023 nous de pouvoir disposer
d'une base permettant d'intégrer dans le
décret qui sera ainsi pris des
modulations des règles d'indemnisation
tenant compte de la conjoncture
économique et plus particulièrement du
marché de l'emploi ces choses faites et
nous souhaitions aussi que le système de
bonus malus appliqué au 7 secteurs les
plus exposés au recours au contrats
2024 avec la conviction que c'est un bon
outil pour lutter contre la précarité
dans ces secteurs le texte le permet
aussi d'autres dispositions étaient
portées présentées par le gouvernement
en matière de validation des acquis de
l'expérience mais Carole Grangeon il
reviendra dans un instant je voudrais
simplement souligner qu'avec l'adoption
du texte et notamment l'ajoute par le
Sénat et après des débats juridiques de
la conjoncture économique au sein de
l'article 54 22-2 du Code du travail
j'aurai l'occasion de continuer la
concertation ouverte avec les
partenaires sociaux en la matière et le
21 novembre de leur présenter les
arbitrages les options retenus par le
gouvernement pour mettre en place cette
modulation des règles d'indemnisation
nous travaillons sur une modulation de
la durée maximum d'indemnisation et pour
répondre à un certain nombre de propos
que j'ai pu entendre ou lire ici ou là
nous ne prévoyons pas de modifier les
conditions d'affiliation au système
d'assurance chômage et donc Nous ne
diminuerons pas le nombre de personnes
en capacité d'ouvrir des droits à
l'assurance chômage puisque nous
maintenons cette période de 6 mois
travaillé sur les 24 derniers mois né de
la réforme de 2019 il y a un certain
nombre de dispositions qui ont aussi
adopté adoptés par les partenaires
sociaux qui nous paraissent par donner
on va parler parlementaires disposition
qui nous paraissent particulièrement
utile notamment en matière de
sécurisation de la présomption de
démission pour ce qui concerne les
abandons de poste y compris en prévoyant
la possibilité pour les salariés qui
connaîtraient une situation de danger de
pouvoir le signaler et ainsi d'être
protégé des discussions des dispositions
de compromis ont aussi été trouvé en
commission mixte paritaire pour encadrer
le dispositif prévoyant de privé de
l'accès à l'aéro des demandeurs d'emploi
qui auraient refusé à deux reprises
pendant l'année un contrat a duré
indéterminé à la suite d'un CDD ou d'une
mission d'intérim je partage les mêmes
réserves et les mêmes interrogations que
monsieur le rapporteur mais les
dispositions adoptées à l'occasion de la
commission mixte paritaire nous
permettent d'envisager un dispositif qui
sera possible protecteur et surtout qui
n'entraînera pas de difficultés en
matière de recours à l'intérieur ou de
conclusion de contrats de CD de CDD de
quelques mois souvent
utile au bon fonctionnement des
entreprises d'autres dispositions ont
été intégrées par à l'occasion du débat
parlementaire je pense notamment au fait
que les Centres de Gestion de la
Fonction Publique Territoriale serait
appelée à se prononcer sur les
éligibilité à la location dans le retour
à l'emploi d'un certain nombre de
démissionnaires de la fonction publique
là aussi le sujet est complexe mais avec
nos collègues en charge des
collectivités locales nous aurons
l'occasion de pouvoir travailler et
avancer sur ce point là je termine
madame la Présidente en remercions à
nouveau l'ensemble des membres de la
commission mixte paritaire pour ces
travaux conclusifs et en renouvellement
en renouvelant mes remercie l'ensemble
des députés représentants de chacun des
groupes pour leur participation et le
fait que nous puissions nous trouver à
cet instant de la procédure et donc
justement l'adoption des conclusions je
l'espère de la commission Mixa par étape
merci Monsieur la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre de l'église
chargé de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion chez Olivier madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés la suite de
monsieur le ministre je tenais également
à saluer la large mobilisation de
l'Assemblée sur ce texte et remercier
tout particulièrement c'est
ces implications notamment celle de
Monsieur leur rapporteur celle également
des membres de la commission des
affaires sociales et de madame la
Présidente pour leur investissement en
faveur d'un dialogue social constructif
et ambitieux sur ce projet de réforme à
ce titre je tiens à saluer
l'investissement des députés Astrid
panoson Bouvet Philippe Vigier Frédéric
Valtou et Stéphane Viry qui par leur
contribution ont permis à ce texte toute
l'envergure toute l'envergure pardon
qu'il méritait je dois enfin rendre
hommage au travail de la commission
mixte paritaire qui a su donner à la
nation un texte fondateur pour notre
méthode inciter au retour à l'emploi
tout en renforçant l'employabilité de
nos concitoyens l'objet de l'article 4
était de répondre à trois objectifs
simplifier moderniser sécuriser c'est
donc un succès effectivement ce texte
procède à une simplification drastique
de la validation des acides d'expérience
pour en ouvrir grand les portes à
travers cette réforme notre premier
objectif était de simplifier la
validation des acquis d'expérience pour
qu'elle reprenne tous son sens dans le
les parcours professionnels des français
grâce à l'engagement du Groupe les
républicains nous rendrons plus
attractive moins administratives pour
que cette VAE soit enfin accessible à
tous et notamment aux personnes les
moins qualifiées c'est donc une nouvelle
procédure qui va se déployer
progressivement et permettre de tourner
la page à une approche trop
administrative parfois réglementaire
nous créerons un parcours basé sur la
confiance avec les candidats plus
respectueux de leurs compétences et dans
lequel l'oralité retrouvera une place de
choix
je voudrais également insister sur le
fait que nous avons à sécuriser les
parcours pour multiplier les succès ce
pari sera tenu et par cette réforme les
membres de la majorité ont permis de
doubler le congé de validation des
acquis d'expérience de tous les salariés
et ont ouvert une voie à un
accompagnement de bout en bout je m'y
suis engagée et ce texte nous le permet
nous travaillerons avec l'ensemble des
certificateurs à l'évolution des règles
de composition et d'organisation des
jurys pour que plus jamais un candidat
ne soit contraint d'attendre 8 mois pour
accéder à la certification enfin
sécuriser c'est aussi réduire cet délai
administratif pour que la VAE devienne
pertinente dans les trajectoires
professionnelles et personnelles pour
que les stratégies d'entreprise puissent
voir jour grâce à ce texte nous pourrons
le réussir enfin grâce à ce texte vous
permettez la VAE d'entrer dans le 21e
siècle nous déploirons progressivement
une plateforme numérique en appuie à
d'un véritable service public accessible
à tous sur un principe d'universalité
qui permet d'organiser la coopération
entre les
celle-ci sera dédiée à la promotion et
au conseil mais aussi au suivi des
parcours elle sera un point d'entrée
unique et identifiable de tous au
service des candidats comme des acteurs
de la VAE elle aura pour mission de
promouvoir les parcours de validation
des acquis d'expérience auprès des
publics qui aujourd'hui en sont parfois
éloignés au premier chef desquels les
proches aidants et les bénévoles nous
offrons également un cadre nouveau de
gouvernance ou devrais-je dire de
coopération entre les acteurs compétents
en matière de validation des acides
d'expérience car je sais que c'est en
partageant nos expertises et nos
ambitions que les acteurs de terrain
pourront effectivement parvenir à leurs
objectifs avec le concours du National
et évidemment cette imbrication du
National et du régional et déterminant
dans la réussite de ce dispositif c'est
tout le sens du GIP que ce texte
installe désormais
après le vote de ce texte par les
chambres c'est une nouvelle étape
fondamentale qui nous attend cette étape
c'est celle de qui relève de la
compétence du gouvernement je veux bien
sûr parler des travaux réglementaires
qui s'ouvriront jusqu'à la fin de
l'année et vous pourrez compter sur mon
engagement pour que ces textes que nous
prendrons soient à la hauteur de
l'ambition que vous exprimez
certainement par ce vote aujourd'hui
j'aurais également le plaisir
d'organiser les conditions du
déploiement d'une véritable innovation
en matière de formation la validation
des acquis de l'expérience inversée et
par décret nous préciserons les
conditions requises pour la mettre en
oeuvre je suis convaincue qu'elle
répondra avec efficacité aux difficultés
de recrutement que rencontrent de
nombreux secteurs notamment ceux de la
santé du sanitaire et du social en
offrant une nouvelle voie d'acquisition
des compétences cette voix promeut une
nouvelle approche de la certification
résolument moins scolaire mesdames et
messieurs les députés c'est grâce à un
travail de collaboration efficace que
nous sommes fiers de vous soumettre ces
articles votre vote ouvre la voie à
droit renforcé celui d'une
reconnaissance universelle des
compétences acquise tout au long de la
vie c'est une condition de réussite de
la Société des compétences et du plein
emploi merci à vous merci madame la
ministre
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale une notion de
Roger préalable déposée en application
de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à Madame Nathalie auziol
pour une durée maximale de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre chers
collègues il n'y avait déjà pas grand
chose à sauver de la première version du
projet de loi portant sur le marché du
travail soit disant en vue du plein
emploi
la deuxième version réalise la prouesse
d'aller encore plus loin dans le
détricotage du Code du travail
on ne code plus les assauts faits sur
les chômeurs au cours des derniers
quinquennats la dernière réforme de
l'assurance chômage en date a été menée
sous la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron et
pour quel résultat vous refusez
systématiquement de tirer le bilan des
dernières réformes alors comptez sur
nous pour le faire
1,15 millions de personnes ont vu leur
indemnisation diminuée 500 000 personnes
ont vu l'ouverture de leurs droits
retardé c'est à dire qu'on fait
doublement peser sur ces personnes le de
ne pas avoir d'emploi d'abord parce
qu'ils n'en ont toujours pas et ensuite
on les pénalisant aux porte-monnaies
sachez que personne n'a plaisir à
demander des aides de l'État personne
n'a plaisir à rester des oeuvrés chez
soi car le chômage n'engage pas que le
chômeur c'est tout l'entourage qui en
paye le prix l'effet n'en est que plus
désastreux sur la personne sans emploi
par ailleurs il nous semblait avoir
entendu à peu près à chaque trimestre du
précédent quinquennat que le chômage
n'avait jamais été aussi bas pourquoi
alors pour suivre la chasse à des
chômeurs qui auraient retrouvé du
travail grâce à l'efficacité
jupitérienne le filtre sélectif des
catégories de chômeurs ne peut pas
longtemps faire illusion et d'ailleurs
s'il n'y a pas de travail il est
difficile d'en trouver car la vérité
c'est qu'il y a 15 demandeurs d'emploi
pour une offre d'emploi vacante
et de quel type d'emploi parle-t-on près
de 4 millions de personnes travaillent
en emploi précaires dans ce pays
87% des embauches ont lieu en contrat
court en 1982 un précaire sur deux
obtenait un CDI au bout d'un an
aujourd'hui c'est seulement un sur cinq
une baisse de 25% des droits ou de 15%.
code rouge les règles en vigueur sont
maintenues car le chômage est de toute
façon trop à ce moment là
après les numéros verts la palette de
l'absurdité macronienne se diversifient
on y comprend plus grand chose mais une
chose est certaine tout le monde y perd
or pour faire passer ce texte de loi la
minorité présidentielle a eu besoin de
se trouver des alliés de circonstances
et des alliés de circonstances elle
trouva au Sénat chez les républicains
ensemble ils ont trouvé comment pousser
plus loin leur acharnement contre les
chômeurs main dans la main ils ont
inscrit la fin des indemnisations
chômage pour les intérimaires et les
personnes en CDD qui refuseront deux
fois un CDI sur le poste
occupé pour reprendre les termes de mon
collègue cloué c'est la triple peine si
on refuse un CDI c'est que le poste
occupé ne convient pas soit parce que on
n'est pas formé pour ce poste soit parce
que ce n'est pas ce qu'on recherche soit
parfois les deux or les gens sont
souvent poussés contraints à prendre le
poste qui se présent pour pouvoir amener
de l'argent à la maison ensuite proposer
ce poste non désiré en CDI est une
deuxième offense quand on sait les
difficultés qu'il y a maintenant à
décrocher un emploi stable et que la
fois où il se présente cet emploi stable
c'est pour un boulot qu'on a pas de
plaisir à exercer enfin voilà que si ce
CDI refusait deux fois la personne se
verra privée des aides pour lesquelles
elle pensait avoir cotisée c'est un
cynisme sans fond vous macroniste
tricher même avec les règles de la
liberté que vous prétendez chérir autre
mesure absolument inique actée par la
minorité présidentielle et les
républicains mains dans la main la
présomption de démission pour les
abandon de poste qui privera là encore
le salarié de ses allocations chômage
nous pensons maintenant à toutes les
travailleuses et à tous les travailleurs
que votre politique de harcèlement a mis
en burn-out à tous les travailleurs qui
traversent des épisodes de dépression
parce qu'il ne voit plus de sens à ce
qu'ils font à tous les travailleurs qui
ont le corps cassé par des mouvements
répétitifs au travail à tous les
travailleurs dans la restauration rapide
par exemple qui se voit notifié leur fin
de période d'essai et qui sont sommets
de finir le mois quand même pour tous
ces gens votre réforme est une attaque
méprisante une provocation et honte
mépris aussi pour les syndicats dont pas
un le soutien cette réforme cruelle
des alliés la macronie on trouve a
également chez le rassemblement national
déjà dans le JDD leur gourou Marine Le
Pen a répété au cas où il y aurait eu un
doute qu'elle votera contre
l'augmentation du SMIC comme elle a voté
contre la taxation des profits et contre
l'impôt sur la fortune pas étonnant donc
que le RN est voté pour l'inéligibilité
de l'assurance chômage en cas de refus
de CDI
par cette notion de rejet nous rappelons
la position de la nupes qui est la
suivante la planification et
l'investissement public d'ailleurs
défendre l'assurance chômage c'est
défendre le travail travaillez moins
pour travailler mieux et travailler tous
il est temps de mettre en place la
garantie d'emploi que propose la nupes
pour tout chômeurs de longue durée une
proposition d'embauche au minimum au
SMIC revalorisé dans un secteur
d'urgence sociale ou écologique le temps
de travail des salariés français n'a pas
diminué depuis 2002 la dernière fois
qu'ils ont obtenu une semaine de congés
payés remonte à 40 ans et pourtant la
réduction du temps de travail est un
progrès social un progrès humain quelque
chose qui permet de reposer le corps de
reposer l'esprit de libérer également du
temps autre que celui consacré au
travail du temps de loisirs du temps
pour la famille et c'est aussi une
nécessité quand les emplois viennent à
manquer
la réduction du temps de travail et donc
à la fois un objectif historique la
politique la plus juste la plus efficace
et la moins coûteuse contre l'usure des
salariés et le sous-emploi
et puis une société où on travaille
moins une société où on travaille mieux
c'est celle où la retraite est à 60 ans
à taux plein avec 40 annuité de
cotisations et vous nous trouverez sur
votre chemin pour la défendre coûte que
coûte en résumé entre vous et nous ce
sont des collections de la Société qui
s'affrontent en vous attaquant au
montant de l'indemnisation vous
affaiblissez volontairement le rapport
de force des demandeurs d'emploi avec
les patrons vous mettez en concurrence
les salariés entre eux et vous poussez
tout le monde à travailler plus
longtemps tandis que l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé elle diminue seulement
vous avez perdu les élections
législatives vous n'avez pas de mandat
pour appliquer votre vision
c'est la nupesse qui a gagné le premier
tour des élections législatives ne vous
en déplaisent
AR nous ne sommes pas dupe de vos
alliances de circonstances vous cherchez
à reculer l'éventualité d'une
dissolution qui vous terrorise nous le
redisons ici nous sommes prêts à
gouverner nous avons le programme nous
avons le nombre et nous mettrons en acte
la rupture avec votre néolibéralisme qui
se trouve de toute façon dans l'impasse
avec nous la société retrouvera la
respiration dont elle a besoin
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la députée
alors j'ai reçu plusieurs demandes
d'explication de vote sur cette motion
de rejet
Monsieur Didier LeGac pour Renaissance
et pour 2 minutes oui merci madame la
présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues sans surprise
le groupe renaissance de votera pas
cette motion de rejet de la France
insoumise en effet tout d'abord d'un
point de vue très pratique et très
concret je rappelle que si nous votion
cette motion de rejet cela mettrait tout
simplement dans l'insécurité juridique
l'ensemble des demandeurs d'emploi qui
sont
selon les modalités définies en 2019 et
que nous reconduisons ici de manière
plus fondamentale si nous adoption la
motion de rejet de nos collègues nous
renoncerions également à nous attaquer
aux contrats et à pénaliser les
entreprises qui en usent et en abuse en
effet je pense que nous sommes d'accord
pour dire que nous déplorons tous
l'explosion depuis 20 ans des contrats
courts
ces contrats précaires limité dans le
temps qu'il n'offre pas de possibilités
à nos jeunes salariés de se projeter
dans l'avenir
par ailleurs il faut veiller également
ce que les employeurs qui nous font part
de leurs difficultés réelles à recruter
des salariés ne soient pas non plus
dissuadés de le faire il faut donc
permettre que notre marché du travail
n'oppose pas employeur et salarié enfin
je voudrais également rappeler que notre
système d'assurance chômage avec ce
projet de loi quoi qu'on en dise demeura
l'un des plus sinon le plus protecteur
des grands pays industrialisés le
ministre du Travail Olivier dussobe
c'est d'ailleurs engagé devant nous au
maintien du niveau d'indemnité
que dont bénéficieront les deux mondes
d'emploi conformément à nos engagements
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat mais aussi
conformément à notre souci de pérenniser
notre système notre modèle social pour
toutes ces raisons nous voterons donc
contre cette motion de rejet car nous
avons besoin de cette réforme pour
atteindre l'objectif du plein emploi
demain merci merci Madame Laure La
Valette
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre chers collègues 5,4
millions
5,4 millions c'est le nombre de chômeurs
dans notre pays mais ce ne sont pas
seulement 5,4 millions de chômeurs ce
sont des personnes des personnes
mesdames messieurs les ministres
figurez-vous qu'elles ont une vie un
frigo à remplir des enfants à élever des
patients à faire vivre et cette vie est
bien souvent ancrée dans un territoire
précis un territoire d'ailleurs que ces
personnes n'ont pas envie de quitter
pour trouver un travail mal rémunéré aux
conditions de travail insatisfaisantes
ou tout simplement un travail qui ne
correspond pas à leurs compétences alors
évidemment si nous reconnaissons
l'urgence à légiférer en matière
d'emplois nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accepter votre vision du travail vous
nous avez habitué à une brutalité
certaine et particulièrement à
destination des chômeurs alors si la
punition et la culpabilisation sont à
l'ordre du jour avec ce texte les
réponses au problématiques de l'emploi
elle ne le sont pas monsieur le ministre
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le rappeler
ici mais une piqûre de rappel semble à
propos huit Français sur 10 considèrent
que la demande d'une augmentation immé
et général des salaires et justifiés ne
les voyez-vous pas chers collègues dans
vos circonscriptions toutes ces
personnes dont le métier ne permet plus
de vivre dignement je pense ici
évidemment à toutes ces professions
épuisantes mal payées avec des horaires
instables créant une charge mentale
parfois insoutenable aide-soignant
policier agriculteurs chauffeur-livreur
professeur employé de restauration
rapide femme de ménage conducteur de car
nous avons 5,4 millions de chômeurs
aujourd'hui et ce texte ne permettra pas
de les amener vers ces métiers peu
valoriser pourtant nécessaire et si
précieux ce texte ne comporte finalement
aucune mesure concrétée immédiate pour
un retour vers le plein emploi nous
voterons donc en cohérence la motion de
rejet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
madame Karen et Rody
[Applaudissements]
il ne devrait pas y avoir de 49.3 ça
nous change malgré tout il y a quelque
chose qui ne change pas encore une fois
nous ne savons pas ce que nous allons
voter comment première lecture le
gouvernement réclame les pleins pouvoirs
pour informer à sa guise la sur un
chômage ça nous dire ce qu'il compte en
faire pour Madame born c'est Noël en
valeur un 49-3 parties par-ci un blanc 5
par là si le gouvernement pouvait passer
se passer de l'assemblée et de et des
partenaires sociaux il le ferait mais le
gouvernement a-t-il été suffisamment
sage pour recevoir de tels cadeaux je
crains que non chers collègues le 3
octobre dans cette hémicycle monsieur le
ministre du socle disait ce texte
permettrait de prolonger les règles en
matière des nominations chômage le
lendemain monsieur le rapporteur à bondé
dans le même sens la suppression du
premier article Laurine conséquent
extrêmement dommageable ce serait de
privé de base juridique l'indemnisation
de plus de 2 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi
c'est un fait la loi nécessaire pour
prolonger cette indemnisation or il
suffit d'un décret publié le 29 octobre
dernier pour prolonger les règles
actuelles jusqu'à la fin du mois de
janvier il y a donc pas besoin de ce
projet de loi grossière manipulation oui
vous avez menti devant la représentation
nationale vous avez menti vous osez
encore nous demander un plan sain vous
avez menti et vous osez encore nous
demander de vous faire confiance pour
réformer l'attirance chômage quel mépris
de notre assemblée alors non vous n'avez
pas été sage nous ne vous ferons donc
aucun cadeau d'autant plus que cette
version expire que la précédente les
députés du groupe elle est finie votre
donc pour cette motion de rejet et
permettez-moi de terminer à vous
rappelant les mots du GO le travail ne
peut être une loi sans être un droit
alors commencez par donner du travail
aux Français au lieu de punir ce qui
n'en trouve pas ce serait déjà ce serait
un bien meilleur cadeau pour nos
concitoyens que ce projet de loi
merci madame la députée monsieur
Stéphane Viry
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame à présent quelques mots sur
cette motion de rejet préalable proposée
par la France insoumise nous souhaitons
l'écarter et nous votre compte pour une
raison assez simple nous sommes arrivés
au terme d'un parcours législatif qui
nous a permis effectivement d'aboutir à
une situation législative par quoi
législative faut-il le dire et le
reconnaître elle assumer ou le groupe
les républicains étaient forces de
proposition tant ici à l'Assemblée qu'au
Sénat et cette version du texte a été
enrichie et nous l'assumons et nous ne
voyons pas pourquoi aujourd'hui nous
souhaiterions effectivement écarter
quelque chose qui globalement apporte
une pierre à l'édifice par rapport au
marché du travail deuxièmement il faut
effectivement donner une base légale à
l'indemnisation des chômeurs et nous
avons besoin d'une loi à Brive délai et
ce texte fut-il par faire par la suite
mérite de poser cette base légale et
puis puisque c'est une proposition au
débat proposée par la France insoumise
doit-on le dire fondamentalement nous ne
partageons pas les points de vue de la
France insoumise sur le travail et sur
l'économie pour lequel nous ne voterons
pas cette motion de rejet préalable
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
naturellement le groupe démocrate ne
soutiendra pas cette motion de rejet
préalable de la nuit pèse mais notre
collègue Adrien Clouet n'en sera pas
surpris la première raison qu'il faut
dire à tout le monde c'est que s'il n'y
avait pas ce texte chers collègues et je
m'adresse au rassemblement national
comme je m'adresse aux insoumis ça veut
dire que vous allez expliquer aux 5
millions 400 000 chômeurs Madame La
Valette vous allez expliquer aux 5
millions à 400 000 chômeurs qu'à partir
du 1er janvier 2023 il n'y aura plus de
base juridique d'indemnisation chômage
c'est ça que vous voulez faire c'est ça
que vous voulez en les mettant dans la
précarité nous non vous oui la deuxième
chose je m'adresse à la collègue
insoumise de la mélenchonie
pardonnez-moi j'utilise les mêmes mots
qu'elle a utilisé ne faites pas aux uns
ce qu'on n'aime pas que l'on vous fasse
et je veux dire à la collègue de la
mélangeonie
que lorsque vous parlez de précarité et
que vous avez un texte comme celui-là
qui prévoit justement d'accélérer le
passage au CDI ça veut dire que vous
protéger la précarité vous protéger les
CDD nous on protège ceux qui veulent une
carrière avec un CDI et qui permettront
demain d'acheter une voiture d'avoir un
appartement et non d'être jeter dans
cette précarité pour toutes ces raisons
niveau trop bas votre texte
merci Monsieur député monsieur de la
porte
il faut parfois être bien assis pour
écouter ces contre-vérités je vais
d'ailleurs vous citer le ministre du
socle qui écrivait sur son facebook en
2013 à lire pour répondre au contre
vérités qui circulent sur le net je vous
aurais plutôt invité monsieur le
ministre à dire à écouter les débats qui
se passent dans ces missiles pour éviter
de propager de nouvelles contre vérités
comme on vient de l'entendre parce que
vous savez pendant plusieurs semaines on
a dit votre réforme n'est pas nécessité
par l'urgence vous n'avez dit mais bien
sûr que si il nous faut une réforme au
1er novembre on vous dit non vous pouvez
prendre un décret pour la proroger le
temps de faire des négociations de faire
du dialogue social de discuter vraiment
au Parlement qu'avez-vous fait vous avez
pris un décret finalement après nous
avoir dit qu'il fallait une loi pour
prolonger à partir du 1er novembre les
règles en vigueur du régime de
l'assurance chômage c'est bien la preuve
qui avait pas besoin d'une loi en toute
urgence pas d'urgence pas nécessité
budgétaire pas nécessité non plus de
mépriser le Parlement c'est pourtant ce
que vous avez fait pendant maintenant un
mois et
une concertation avec les députés
fantoche je veux dire il y a rien eu on
parlait de co-construction moi j'ai pas
eu d'appel qui me disait tiens qui est
l'amendement tu veux qu'est-ce que tu
portes enfin si j'en ai marre puis on
m'a dit non en fait finalement ton
amendement il est nul on va pas le
prendre donc voilà voilà ce à quoi c'est
limité votre pseudo concertation et on
m'a dit en fait on te prend ton
amendement si uniquement tu votes pour
le texte bah écoutez moi je veux juste
améliorer le texte un amendement sur le
recours qu'avez-vous fait vous l'avez
refusé il était génial c'est amendement
bon ben voilà c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça que vous êtes comporté avec nous vous
avez fait une CMP qui a duré 1h08 1h08
pour donner des cadeaux à la droite mais
pour refuser évidemment tout ce qu'on
vous proposer vous avez un texte de
régression sociale qui est refusé par
l'ensemble des syndicats qui est refusé
par une partie de la majorité
parlementaire et qui de pardon partie de
l'opposition parlementaire et qui repose
sur une base juridique non nécessaire
bref c'est pour ça qu'on soutiendra
cette motion de rejet évidemment vous en
doutez c'est pour ça qu'on déplore les
regrets et avec grand regret tous les
toutes les régressions sociales que
contient le texte et nous obtiendrons
la parole est à Monsieur Val tout
oui madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur bien sûr que le groupe
horizon dans la continuité des débats de
ces dernières semaines soutiendra ce
projet de loi et le votera votre acompte
pardon la motion de rejet pour ensuite
soutenir ce projet de loi évoqué pour
celui-là on a entendu de la part
effectivement de la troupe mélenchoniste
énormément de contre-vérité énormément
de caricatures des discours de posture
pardon mais des discours de posture on a
l'impression mesdames et messieurs vous
n'avez pas lu le projet de loi et vous
n'avez pas lu la version enrichie par
les travaux parlementaires soyons fiers
que ce Parlement travaille soyons fiers
que ce Parlement amende les textes
soyons fiers que les deux chambres
puissent aussi travailler de concert et
soyons faire de voir un fait un texte
qui aura été au bout de la discussion
parlementaire et qui amènera
effectivement dans un contexte de
économique que vous connaissez dans un
contexte effectivement ou moi aussi je
peux citer des chiffres et je chiffre je
citerai le chiffre 7,3% de chômeurs dans
un contexte où on doit progresser vers
la société de plein emploi et bien ce
texte permettra permettra des avancées
et c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
souligner les avancées j'y reviendrai
dans la discussion générale sur la
effectivement l'expérimentation des CDD
multi-remplacement et sur un certain
nombre d'autres dispositions et la Vee
n'en est pas un des moins il était
nécessaire ce texte il est nécessaire
parce qu'il doit donner mais les
orateurs précédents l'ont dit aussi une
base légale un admission l'indemnisation
des chômeurs je n'y reviendrai pas
finalement au travers cette notion de
rejet que vous nous proposez ces deux
visions du parlementarisme qui
s'opposent et qui effectivement nous
différencie il y a le parlementarisme
d'outrans il y a le parlementarisme
effectivement de posture et
effectivement le discours que vous nous
avez servi nous là effectivement bien
montré et puis il y a le parlementarisme
constructif qui cherche effectivement à
apporter dans le concret des textes des
mesures concrètes pour les Français ce
texte y répond votre motion Roger
l'opposé nous la rejetons et là encore
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues valent tout il y a aussi le
parlementarisme de conviction j'en veux
pour preuve parce que c'est mur ont une
mémoire quand en avril 2008 un jeune
parlementaire avisé déclaré la politique
qui consiste à faire des demandeurs
d'emploi les responsables de leur sort a
déjà fait maintes fois la preuve de sa
nocivité et de son
inefficacité je répète de sa nocivité et
de son inefficacité ce député avisé
c'était le ministre Olivier du soft
[Applaudissements]
les mots la mémoire les murs ont la
mémoire chers collègues or en retournant
sa veste le ministre a aussi changé de
conviction et s'est enfermé dans un
indéni je passe sur le déni de
démocratie par Le Mans méprisé appelé à
voter un blanc simple partenaire sociaux
méprisé et humilié une fois de plus déni
de dignité quand par dinepte modulation
des droits vous ferez et vous faites des
chômeurs des variables d'ajustement
économique comment la promesse
républicaine d'égalité peut-être tenue
quand deux salariés qui auront travaillé
la même durée pour le même salaire
n'auront pas la même indemnisation c'est
cruel tout ça parce que vous gouvernez
avec une calculette en réalité pour une
seule raison baisser les indemnités des
chômeurs et puis déni de réalité parce
que votre postulat et je veux quand même
avoir une pensée alors que nous vivons
une journée triste pour les droits des
chômeurs pour la République sociale pour
celles et ceux qui ont assisté pendant
des semaines à des débats qui rester à
dire que ceux qui n'avaient pas de
travail étaient des fainéants
responsables de leur sort qui a expliqué
que ceux qui étaient aidés qui
bénéficiaient de leur juste indemnité
était dans un luxe vous avez vous partez
si vous l'avez dit ou en tout cas vous
l'avez clairement sous-entendu pourtant
la réalité c'est que quatre demandeurs 4
demandeurs d'emploi sur des seulement
sont indemnisés et parmi eux beaucoup
travaillent partiellement 50% des
allocataires ont eu une indemnité
journalière inférieure à 34 euros alors
en réalité vous vous enfermez dans votre
idéologie pour fuir les vrais sujets les
salaires et les conditions de travail
alors je vous indique je vous indique
que je suis saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public sur la motion de rejet
préalable par le groupe socialiste et
apparenté le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale mais
attendez il y a encore des explications
de vote j'annonce ce scrutin
merci madame la Présidente ainsi donc
nous aurons une réforme de droite qui va
rassembler la droite qui sera votée par
la droite et qui a été conçue par la
droite avec cet arrangement qui a été
trouvé en commission mixte paritaire
comme si nos débats étaient trop court
ici au Parlement depuis quelques
semaines déjà tous les débats sont
tronqués et celui-ci ne n'y fera pas
défaut puisque vous êtes mis d'accord
entre vous alors que nous aurions sans
doute pu prolonger cette discussion
essayer de vous faire entendre raison or
le texte tel qu'il ressort de
l'expérience sénatoriale a été
considérablement durci il était déjà une
attaque contre les chômeurs et il va
être renforcé par les mesures qui ont
été adoptées au Sénat et que le
gouvernement a accepté de reprendre à
son compte à l'occasion de la commission
mixte paritaire tout à l'heure notre
collègue Stéphane virer Viry a dit que
il s'agissait d'un parcours et que le
parcours législatif avait été à son
terme dans parcours il y a cours et là
il a été effectivement très très court
il y a donc dans cette réforme des
inégalités nouvelles inégalités de
droits qui sont créées il y a des
réductions d'accès aux droits alors que
nous avons commencé cette discussion en
apprenant par un rapport qui a fini par
nous être rendu par le gouvernement avec
deux ans de retard que au moins un tiers
des personnes qui pouvaient être
indemnisées ne faisait pas valoir leurs
droits il y a une réforme de la VAE qui
a été faite sur le pouce c'est
d'ailleurs un cavalier législatif et
donc une conception du travail qui en
qui relève de Tetris ou vous voulez
simplement emboîter des cubes une
conception du travail qui relève du
passage piéton il suffirait de traverser
la rue pour trouver un boulot ce qui
avait été dit par le Président de la
République en son temps et qu'il a
assumé dans cette discussion vous avez
expulsé les partenaires sociaux et donc
vous avez choisi en réalité de prendre
la main et de produire cette mauvaise
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui va
aggraver la situation pour les chômeurs
de notre pays merci
dernière intervenant pour ses
explications de vote monsieur Colombani
merci madame la Présidente dès le début
notre groupe était plus que réservé sur
ce projet de loi nous avons le sentiment
d'avoir été mis devant le fait accompli
en nous disant qu'il était obligatoire
de légiférer avant la fin de l'année
faute de quoi les règles actuelles
d'assurance chômage sur les caduque face
à l'urgence de la situation nous avons
plaidé pour une prolongation à
l'identique des règles actuelles en vain
aujourd'hui on a encore le sentiment
d'être mis devant le fait accompli avec
le texte qui nous revient du Sénat qui
n'est plus tout à fait le même que celui
adopté ici il s'agit d'un vrai
bouleversement de notre système
d'assurance chômage or les équilibres en
commission mixparitaire ont été fait au
détriment des travailleurs et les
demandeurs d'emploi aucune étude est
d'impact aucun argument n'accompagne les
disposition restrictive qui ont été
intégrés notre groupe déplore que le
gouvernement a décidé de contourner le
dialogue social pour décider des
nouvelles règles surtout nous ne savons
quasiment rien du décret en préparation
si ce n'est quelques éléments peu
rassurants qui ont fuité dans la presse
nous avons aucune certitude sauf une que
les droits du chômage vont baisser aussi
cette motion de rejet aussi sur cette
notion de rejet les votes du groupe
refléteront notre position sur le texte
que nous essaie que nous estimons une
adaptés aux objectifs poursuivis
merci alors je vais mettre au revoir
avec un scrutin public
la motion de rejet je vous invite à
regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin à votant 310 exprimé
309 majorité 155 pour 121 contre 188
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
alors je vais ouvrir la discussion
générale sur le texte de la CMP en
commençant par Madame Astrid panozio
Bouvet pour le groupe Renaissance et
pour 5 minutes
mes chers collègues je vous invite à
sortir en silence pour celles et ceux
qui quittent les mystiques
comment on fait pour monter le truc
comme ça
[Musique]
le ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur cher collègue on
peut se réjouir avec le Sénat nous
soyons parvenus un accord sur les moyens
d'atteindre un objectif commun
résolument attendu des Français la lutte
contre le chômage en vue du plein emploi
ce projet de loi ne constitue qu'une
première étape dans une stratégie de
long terme pour que chaque concitoyen
puisse exercer un emploi stable et
durable pour vivre dignement de son
travail et se construire une meilleure
vie c'est cette responsabilité qui nous
incombe et nous réunit aujourd'hui le
Parlement c'est pleinement mobilisé sur
ce texte pour aboutir à un texte
équilibré juste et efficace
ce projet de loi répond tout d'abord à
une situation d'urgence pour éviter un
vide juridique ça a été dit qui aurait
pu mettre en péril l'indemnisation de
nombreux demandeurs d'emploi il donne au
gouvernement les moyens d'agir pour
préserver le fonctionnement de
l'assurance chômage et il offre de
nouvelles perspectives au rôle essentiel
du paritarisme ce texte permet également
de moduler l'assurance chômage en
fonction d'indicateurs conjoncturel le
Sénat a souhaité consacrer ce principe
de contracyclicité dans la loi
de nouvelles dispositions équilibrées
promovent aussi l'emploi stable et
durable d'une part du point de vue des
employés notamment en encourageant les
bénéficiaires d'un contrat court à
accepter une offre de CDI ils ne
pourront plus ainsi percevoir leur
allocation chômage après deux refus dans
les 12 mois et un décret viendra fixer
les modalités d'application très
opérationnelles de ces dispositions qui
requièrent des adaptations tant de la
part des employeurs que de Pôle emploi
ou en renouvellement renouvellement
l'expérimentation des CDD multi
remplacement entravés en raison de la
crise sanitaire ces deux dernières
mesures nécessitent une évaluation plus
globale sur les alternatives au CDI qui
se sont créées ces dernières années
et d'autre part du point de vue des
employeurs en améliorant la transparence
du taux de séparation dans le dispositif
du bonus malus afin de comporter ce
mécanisme et en luttant contre les
abandons de poste avec la fin de
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
qui ne se retrouveraient pas dans une
situation de privation involontaire
d'emploi cette contribution des députés
des groupes Renaissance démocrates
horizons et LR répond à une vraie
réalité de terrain que nous rencontrons
tous les jours nous le savons la
formation tout au long de la vie est
essentielle pour accélérer à l'emploi et
la mobilité professionnelle ce texte
crée un véritable service public de la
VAE troisième voie aux côtés de la
formation continue et de la formation
initiale un dispositif ouvert à toute
personne qui justifie d'une activité en
lien avec le contenu de la certification
c'est une avancée majeure
toutes ces mesures ne seraient à elle
seule permettre d'atteindre le plein
emploi et mieux encore le Blaise le bon
emploi qui doit être notre cap et dans
le cadre de France travail monsieur le
ministre nous devons aller plus loin
pour nous atteler à lever les freins non
monétaires à l'emploi comme les
transports la garde d'enfants ou le
logement a poursuivre notre nos efforts
pour lutter contre les discriminations à
l'embauche 30% de chance en moins d'être
contacté après avoir postulé parce qu'on
a un prénom d'origine supposé étrangère
comme nous leur avalait la DARES en 2021
et investir plus encore dans la
formation tout en simplifiant et en
automatisant l'accès aux allocations
chômage avec 40% de nos recours comme
nous l'avons appris récemment mes chers
collègues je vous invite donc à voter
pour ce texte qui est une première étape
importante pour avancer vers l'emploi
durable pour tous je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Victor Catteau
pour le groupe rassemblement national et
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames messieurs
les ministres madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue cela fait maintenant 45 ans 45
ans que la France n'a pas connu le plein
emploi depuis 45 ans les gouvernements
se sont succédés clairement toujours
plus haut et plus fort les objectifs
plus ambitieux les uns que les autres
pourtant vous l'avez deviné si nous nous
retrouvons à discuter de ce projet de
loi aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils ont tous
échoué bien que le chômage est baissé
dans notre pays en lavoisinant les 7,3%
celui-ci demeure deux fois supérieur à
celui de nos voisins européens pourtant
60% des entreprises déclaraient prouvées
des difficultés à recruter ce qui
représente à peu près 400 000 postes à
pourvoir et ce alors même que l'on
recense encore plus de 5 millions de
chômeurs dont 3 millions sans aucune
activité la situation est inédite pour
autant la seule solution que vous y
apportez c'est la répression en effet
votre souhait de vous attribuer indument
la capacité de moduler les règles
d'indemnisation du chômage en fonction
de la conjoncture économique du pays à
l'encon de toute logique pensez-vous
sincèrement que c'est avec la modulation
de la location chômage que vous
arriverez à trouver davantage
d'électricien découvreurs de serveurs de
plombiers ou encore d'aide soignants
croyez-vous sérieusement que faire des
économies en catimini dans le dos des
Français en rognant autoritairement sur
les allocations chômage impactera pas le
pouvoir d'achat des Français en vérité
je ne peux pas croire que vous n'ayez
pas réfléchi aux conséquences néfastes
qu'un durer un pari dispositif je pense
que votre indifférence à l'égard de nos
compatriotes et révélatrices du manque
de considération que vous leur portez on
reconnaît bien la voie de philosophie
celle qui consiste à percevoir les
chômeurs comme des personnes ne voulant
pas travailler sur lesquels il faut
taper encore et toujours plus fort or ne
vous en déplaise les demandeurs d'emploi
ne sont ni défaignants ni des profiteurs
non le chômage n'a rien de plaisant le
chômage est au contraire le plus souvent
vécu comme un véritable échec plus
qu'une perte d'emploi il est même une
perte même de son identité sociale
il est source d'un profond mal-être
d'une immense souffrance ceci dit bien
que nous ne partageons évidemment pas
votre indifférence quant à la souffrance
de nos concitoyens il est vrai que mes
propos ne concernent ici qu'une grande
majorité des personnes privées d'emplois
et non l'infiminalité qui abuse du
système et face à laquelle il faut en
effet nous montrer extrêmement ferme
c'est pourquoi nous approuvons l'idée de
priver d'indemnisation chômage des
salariés refusant par deux fois un CDI
qui leur est proposé nous voyons mal en
effet comment
œuvrer en faveur de la pérennisation
nécessaire des emplois et en même temps
accepter le fait que certains se content
de cumuler des CDD de la même manière
nous approuvons le principe de présumer
démissionnaires toutes salariés
abandonnant son poste puisqu'il n'est
clairement pas acceptable qu'il puisse
après cela percevoir un jugement une
allocation chômage comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
toutefois soutenant toujours la
pérennisation des emplois nous ne
pouvons que nous montrer hostile à la
volonté de supprimer la limite des 36
mois applicables aux missions intérim
celle-ci étant complètement contraire à
la lutte contre la Périgord précarité de
l'emploi aussi nous l'avons dit la
situation est inédite et cette situation
n'est pas le simple fait du hasard quand
des secteurs entiers tels que
l'hôtellerie la restauration ou encore
le tourisme rencontre une sévère pénurie
de main d'oeuvre cela ne peut pas être
dû à une simple conjoncture économique
ne partageant évidemment pas la vie de
François Mitterrand qui disait que l'on
a tout essayé en matière de lutte contre
le chômage nous pensons qu'il existe des
solutions bien que vous refusez de les
écouter vous auriez pu permettre aux
entreprises d'augmenter les salaires de
10% jusqu'à trois fois le SMIC en
exonérant cette hausse de charges
patronale comme le proposer Marine Le
Pen mais vous l'avez refusé vous auriez
pu miser davantage sur la formation en
augmentant les moyens accordés
alternance comme le proposer Marine Le
Pen mais vous l'avez également refusé
nous allons donc le répéter une fois
encore espérant que cette fois-ci vous
le comprendrez les 12 et 19 juin dernier
les Français ont fait un choix ils ont
fait le choix de vous placer en minorité
et de nous donner le plus grand groupe
de positions afin que nous les
défendions et c'est pourquoi nous allons
précisément continuer à le faire à la
sablement enfin à l'heure où vous
préférez tourner vers le la main
d'oeuvre étrangère qui je cite fera le
boulot des Français qui le refusent il
apparaît en effet urgent de protéger nos
compatriotes de cette immense
déconnexion qui est à l'image du présent
projet de loi contre lequel nous nous
opposerons évidemment je vous remercie
merci
monsieur le député la parole est un
monsieur Adrien Clouet pour la France
insoumise nupet c'est pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la Présidente collègue ministre
mercredi dernier nous entrions au Sénat
pour discuter de l'avenir des chômeuses
et des chômeurs en petits comités la
réunion a duré exactement une heure et 8
minutes pour liquider l'assurance
hommage soit 1500 chômeurs par seconde
qui perdait leurs droits sous les
soupirs de satisfaction de la droite
macroniste et les républicains enfin
réunifiés lorsqu'il s'agit de taper sur
la tête des plus précaires nous voici
donc devant un projet de loi qui ramasse
les pires propositions
issues de vos rangs respectifs car ce
texte résulte d'un troc à caractère
sordide les républicains ont confié au
gouvernement la main mise d’état sur
l'assurance chômage et en échange les
macronistes sont acceptés de forcer les
salariés précaires à accepter des
emplois pourris bref le deal de cette
commission mix paritaire était passe-moi
des salariés à bas prix je te donne les
clés de l'assurance chômage
tout cela avec en ligne de mire le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
puisque vous baissez l'indemnisation
chômage ce qui obligera à faire des
trimestres supplémentaires pour
maintenir un niveau minimum de pension
auprès des futurs bénéficiaires en
attendant ce texte est un acte
d'irresponsabilité totale vous avez
attendu de prendre en main l'ensemble du
régime d'assurance chômage pour nous
annoncer ce que vous alliez en faire une
fois que vous aviez déjà opté pour cette
solution on doit lire les interviews de
complaisance dans la presse d'un jour à
l'autre pour découvrir les horreurs que
nous réserve le jour suivant dans vos
propos nous n'apprenons désormais qu'en
fin de débat parlementaire à quoi va
ressembler votre modulation des droits
sans jamais sans avoir toujours reçu un
seul document de cadrage ou une seule
note précise sur le montant des
allocations que vous réservez à la
population alors le ministre a inventé
un code couleur infantilisant il y aura
des situations économiques vertes orange
et rouge bon c'est un peu Martine ça
avec l'assurance chômage en l'occurrence
si c'est vert on raccourcira de 25% la
durée des allocations si c'est Orange on
raccourcira de 15%, si c'est rouge on
les maintiendra vous nous vendiez les
mérites de la modulation il y aurait des
gagnants et des perdants c'était bien
sûr un mensonge il n'y aura aucun
gagnant et donc par définition que des
perdants
mais le passage de ce texte au Sénat là
encore aggravé désormais deux refus de
CD de CDI en pêcheront d'être indemnisés
par l'assurance chômage mesurons un
petit peu ce que cela signifie sur le
plan philosophique vous ne poursuivez
pas des gens parce qu'il n'auraient pas
donné suite à des engagements
contractuels vous poursuivez des gens
car ils ne signent pas un contrat donné
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils auraient mal
travaillé parce qu'il n'auraient pas
respecté leurs engagements que vous
adoptez des sanctions c'est parce que il
n'accepte pas de souscrire à des
engagements auxquels vous voulez les
forcer bref vous inventez la punition de
non signature d'un contrat qui n'existe
pas encore et qui est ciblé par une
telle disposition c'est la salarié par
exemple dont l'usine a fermé qui a
accepté un petit boulot d'intérim
alimentaire car elle n'a pas le choix et
fait tous les efforts du monde pour
travailler parfois elle peut rouler deux
heures pour se rendre sur le lieu de
travail et lorsque ça se passe mal elle
peut connaître une angoisse terrible
qu'il a saisi durant la nuit elle peut
connaître des douleurs sur le dos sur
les articulations si l'employeur lui a
proposé un poste inax inacceptable
inadapté mais désormais si ce même
employeur lui propose un CDI voici
qu'elle ne pourra pas être indemnisée à
la fin du contrat en dépit de tous les
efforts qu'elle aura consenti dans le
cadre de son activité c'est elle ce sont
des milliers de gens j'en suis sûr dans
vos circonscriptions qui vont connaître
cette violence que vous manigancez
aujourd'hui que vous voulez imposer sur
l'ensemble du pays car si vous souhaitez
que les CDD deviennent des CDI et bien
interdisez les CDD sans raison valable
rétablissez les visites médicales
périodiques pour avoir des conditions
d'exercice saine et lever le niveau des
salaires pour que les personnes puissent
vivre de leur emploi bloquer les
licenciements pour que enfin le CDD se
transforme en CDI non pas de manière
forcée et contrainte mais uniquement
parce qu'il y a une adéquation entre un
projet un poste un investissement et une
volonté individuelle de se réaliser dans
un travail qui le permet
bref la conséquence de cet ajout
sénatorial est dramatique à l'inverse
même le sens de l'assurance chômage au
lieu de protéger les gens contre une
perte de contrats vous protéger les
employeurs contre leur propre salarié et
les revendications éventuelles qu'ils
auraient c'est pourquoi nous irons
devant le Conseil constitutionnel au
titre des droits inaninables et sacrés
au secours et la fraternité que garantit
notre Constitution et que méconnais le
texte présenté ici cette commission
paritaire mix plus généralement et je
conclus avec cela soulève le problème de
nos institutions nous voici dans une
République où un parti les républicains
étant position d'imposer son programme
par l'intérieur du Sénat pourtant vous
avez obtenu 2 millions de voix aux
élections législatives alors que les
syndicats de salariés faisaient 5
millions durant les scores de
représentativité dit autrement 2
millions de voix pour vous pèsent plus
que 5 millions pour l'ensemble du monde
du travail cette séquence nous montre
l'urgence d'une sixième république où la
loi résulterait du plus grand nombre et
pas les combines de couloir en attendant
c'est non merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Berry
pour 5 minutes pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
de la Commission mes chers collègues et
bien oui nous les républicains nous
inscrivons dans les institutions et nous
cherchons à trouver des solutions pour
la France et à faire avancer le pays
autant qu'il puisse être possible nous
inscrivons pas effectivement dans cette
idée de provoquer le chaos de mettre le
pays dans l'impasse surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit des demandeurs d'emploi et de la
question du marché du travail nous
arrivons au terme d'un parcours
législatif et faut-il le reconnaître et
le dire ce projet de loi ne suffit pas
en soi à régler toute la question du
plein emploi et du sujet majeur de la
valeur travail dans notre pays il y a
bien d'autres choses à faire il a bien
d'autres réformes à entreprendre et
objectivement au terme de nos débats on
peut constater qu'il y a effectivement
deux regards de vision de modèles sur ce
que la France peut proposer en termes de
travail
celui de la gauche et celui de la droite
il y a effectivement une partie de
l'hémicycle sur lequel on ne sait pas où
ils sont on ne comprend pas leur
solution à part provoquer le désordre
provoquer le chaos et considéré que tout
pourrait tout pourrait être fait
autrement moi je considère et je l'avais
dit que ce texte initialement proposé
par le gouvernement était un texte
intérimaire un texte de transition et
dans nos débats le Parlement a pris sa
place et le Parlement a pris toute sa
place et il a enrichi substantiellement
la version initiale proposée par le
gouvernement avait-on le choix le texte
portait sur des mesures d'urgence pour
faciliter l'accès au travail nous
devions prendre nos responsabilités et
faire force de proposition la question
du travail dans notre pays la question
de notre modèle social de notre cohésion
sociale de notre modèle de vie elle est
essentielle et à l'évidence monsieur le
ministre sur ces sujets-là nous y
reviendrons au cours des débats à venir
parce que ce projet de loi il ne suffit
pas à vider le sujet
et on creux faudra-t-il probablement se
poser la question de la finalité de
notre système d'assurance chômage
apporter un revenu de remplacement à
titre provisoire pour une personne qui
perd son emploi avec la nécessité pour
cet homme et pour cette femme de
repartir en emploi autant que possible
aussi rapidement avec toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement et jamais détourner le
système de sa vocation et de s'affiner
les terres originale
nous arrivons donc sur un choix faut-il
ou pas valider la commission mixte
paritaire qui a travaillé la semaine
passée moi je considère que la version
proposée au terme de cette commission
mix paritaire elle apporte 3 3 valeurs 3
3 apports la première chose c'est
qu'elle contribue effectivement au
marché du plein emploi par les décisions
qui sont prises pour faut-il le dire
faut-il le reconnaître inciter à
l'emploi et effectivement faire en sorte
que on aille vers l'emploi aussi
rapidement que possible deuxièmement
cette version elle propose un système
défendant le paritarisme lui redonnant
une chance et ça valait le coup
effectivement d'aller dans cette
direction et troisièmement cette cette
version du texte validé en CMP elle pose
un cadre clair pour la valorisation des
acquis de l'expérience c'est une
excellente chose la valorisation des
acquis de l'expérience cet article 4
c'est effectivement plus accessible
avec un meilleur accompagnement des
candidats et les plus ouvertes c'est
désormais plus de candidats pourront
obtenir une certification en lien avec
leur activité c'est une forme la
troisième voie de la formation qui est
ainsi ressourcée et amplifié dans notre
pays et je crois que chacun peut se
satisfaire le paritarisme je l'ai dit ce
texte lui permet de lui redonner une
chance on adoptant les règles de
l'assurance chômage aux réalités du
marché du travail je le redis en tout
cas les républicains souhaitons
renforcer défendre autant qu'il soit
possible le dialogue social faire
confiance à celles et ceux qui
constituent la démocratie sociale de ce
pays et les associés autant que
nécessaire à tous les sujets qui
concernent le travail et l'emploi
monsieur le ministre l'avait proposé en
amont de nos discussions probablement
faudra-t-il réfléchir à la place du
Parlement sur ces questions de marché du
travail pas uniquement à travers un
projet de loi et peut-être dans le cadre
d'un débat annuel pour que le Parlement
puisse donner sa vision sur les règles
de notre assurance chômage toujours
est-il que ce projet de tel qu'il a été
abouti en CMP il permet une amélioration
du marché du travail et on démo il va
satisfaire à notre économie à nos
entreprises qui pourront mobiliser plus
facilement des ressources humaines
nécessaires à leurs production je l'ai
dit le chant n'est pas vidé il y aura
effectivement d'autres choses à faire et
ça a été dit tout à l'heure sur le
concept d'offre raisonnable d'emploi il
y a une mission en cours pour nous
permettre d'avancer sur le sujet mais
sur l'abandon de poste qui est désormais
présumé sur le refus de CDI après
plusieurs CDD sur un certain nombre de
mesures de la situation à l'emploi ce
texte il va dans la bonne direction et
nous l'assumons il y a également un
regard par rapport aux agents des
collectivités territoriales il y a le
retour à une lettre d'orientation plutôt
que de cadrage il y a manifestement un
texte qui va dans la bonne direction
même si des questions se posent encore
sur la question de la gouvernance de la
chevan chômage et si effectivement nous
devons avoir une prudence sur la
question du déplafonnement du CDI
intérimaire sur lequel nous devons être
excessivement vigilants pour répondre à
la question oui nous allons voter cette
commission X de parité enfin nous allons
le texte qui a été abouti aux
commissions x-paritaires parce que nous
considérons que ça constitue en l'état
une solution pour le marché du travail
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
pour le groupe démocrate et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
mes chers collègues
la démocratie c'est respecté le travail
qui est fait notamment par le Parlement
alors notre collègue disait en une en
une heure huit minutes nous avons conclu
au Sénat l'autre jour 14 parlementaires
acceptés collègues que l'ensemble des
sensibilités politiques étaient
présentées et donc c'est un travail des
deux assemblées il faut respecter la
démocratie vous avez perdu les élections
la mélenchonie c'est comme cela mais
accepter quand même accepter quand même
qu'à un moment ou un autre lorsque le
Parlement se réunion comme ils sont mix
paritaire et bien lorsque
malheureusement vous ne gagnez pas tous
les arbitrages et bien il faut accepter
la démocratie et franchement je ne vous
ressortirai pas la phrase d'André les
Niel mais ça je dis ça pour Monsieur
Delaporte parce que Monsieur Lenny elle
a déclaré à cette tribune vous avez
juridiquement tort parce que vous êtes
politiquement minoritaire nous on vous
la scène pas alors pas de leçon de
morale à ceux qui sont en responsabilité
aujourd'hui
la deuxième chose mes chers collègues ça
a été dit par les deux ministres tout à
l'heure il y avait un vide juridique
chacun le sait se rédemnisation chômage
et sa vie juridique fallait le combler
je me suis permis de le rappeler lorsque
tout à l'heure vous avez souhaité
déposer une motion on renvoie préalable
maintenant
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je crois que
ce texte qui a été élaboré à la fois par
le Sénat l'Assemblée permet simplement
de remettre le paritarisme sur les rails
on peut pas d'un côté expliquer toute la
journée que il faut absolument que les
partenaires sociaux soient au cœur du
débat et puis après on dit non l'Hermit
pas dans les bas justement si vous lisez
bien le texte et j'aurais aimé vous
écouter collègues puisque vous dites pas
cher collègue moi je vous dis collègue
comme vous j'aurais aimé vous écouter
sur vos propositions et les propositions
je les ai pas vu arriver et donc nous
dans les propositions c'est de leur dire
d'ici le 31 décembre 2023 mettez-vous
autour de la table quels sont les règles
d'indemnisation que préconisez-vous et
bien maintenant les pertinentes sociaux
il leur appartient de reprendre la balle
au bon et après et après et j'espère
qu'on ils vont être positifs
constructifs et de manière à ce qu'on
soit en capacité demain d'avoir des
règles d'indemnisation chômage la
troisième chose ça vous choque mais moi
ça me choque pas vous avez dit et bien
écoutez on va mettre des contrats des
éléments contracycliques lorsque ça va
bien
j'estime qu'on doit moins aider que
lorsque ça va mal c'est là où on a une
différence entre vous et nous moi pour
moi c'est aider plus ceux qui en ont
besoin et des moins ceux qui ont le plus
c'est pourtant un message qu'on devrait
entendre régulièrement mais on a du mal
à l'entendre alors alors ensuite ce
texte me semble-t-il par exemple sur
l'abandon de poste nous n'avions voté à
l'assemblée je parle devant les
ministres devant Marc ferratique qui a
fait un travail considérable en liaison
avec les collègues au Sénat et bien
n'abandonne poste on lui a donné me
semble-t-il un encadrement juridique
solide se laisser DDD CDI redisant les
choses à l'Assemblée on était pas arrivé
à cette copie là je suis fait partie de
ceux qui auraient préférés qu'on reste
sur trois refus de CDI bref mais il a
fallu aussi trouver une forme de
compromis avec les collègues sénateurs
les républicains au Sénat ont souhaité
mettre leur poids dans la bataille et
dans la balance pour que ça aille ainsi
c'était un moyen d'avancer mais
j'observe j'observe quand même qu'il y a
socialiste qui était un peu dubitatif
sur ce qu'il allait faire sur le vote
après la VAE voyez pierre daryville
n'est pas là c'est quand même dommage
parce que la VAE c'est la première fois
oui la première fois depuis 20 ans dans
ce pays qu'en fin on va lui donner sens
et on est rentré dans ce texte les
minutes ma voudront pas à voir en
particulier Carole Grandjean ne m'en
voudra pas on était passé quand même par
le petit prisme uniquement des aidants
et qu'on va l'ouvrir considérablement à
toutes les professions tous ceux qui
nous disent vous voyez pas d'entreprise
venez avec nous je me suis occupé d'un
bassin d'emploi d'une Pau donc déjà une
qui était en difficulté et bien la VAE
croyez bien pour ceux qui sont en milieu
rural comme moi qui n'ont pas des
instituts de formation à proximité ça va
être pour eux franchement une étape
considérable alors vous dire chers
collègues que certains évidemment c'est
un compromis mais on va pas tout régler
dans cette ministre a annoncé 7
chantiers en particulier la
transformation en France travail
d'ailleurs pas un mot sur le fait que
l'apprentissage ça fonctionne ça c'est
terminé on a dit plus un mot va pas
marcher pas on n'a pas tous les jours
maintenant que ça marche plus jamais en
parler comme ça au moins on est sûr que
on en parle tout le temps mais donc moi
j'aimerais bien qu'à l'occasion des 7
chantiers qu'on va avoir à partir de oui
mon cher collègue à partir des 7 janvier
qu'on va avoir à partir de janvier parce
que rien ne s'arrête vous savez j'ai un
souvenir chers collègues de la porte un
président de la République qui ne se
représenté par ce qu'il attendait tous
les jours la version de la courte du
chômage j'ai regardé la télé tous les
soirs elle les voyait pas et du coup il
s'est pas représenté donc franchement
acte de modestie imitant nous tous
ensemble autour d'une table pour avancer
on sera plus efficace merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Arthur
de la porte pour l'Europe socialiste et
apparenté et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
trompe l'oeil c'est un procédé de
représentation visant à créer par divers
artifices en jouant sur la confusion de
la perception du spectateur l'illusion
de la réalité il y a des maîtres en la
matière selon la légende le peintre
thexis peignait des raisins si réalistes
que les oiseaux passant par là font sort
droit sur l'oeuvre et pensant ainsi
sustenter ce sont heurtés à la réalité
du mur qui était derrière il y a aussi
les mauvais disciples de Deoxys car
aujourd'hui en tentant de faire passer
pour une réforme de progrès d'une des
pires régressions du quinquennat vous
êtes bien loin d'être l'héritier
monsieur le ministre de thexistes en les
imperfections sont légion
derrière votre gouleyante promesse du
peine emploi car c'est ainsi que
s'intitule votre série de 8 chantiers
dont l'assurance chômage serait le
premier volet se cache bien le mur en
dur auquel se heurteront demain les
personnes en recherche d'un emploi alors
aujourd'hui vous nous demandez de juger
la qualité de la première d'une série de
fresques murales que les spécialistes
d'art pictural renommeront plus
probablement destruction à marche forcée
des acquis du droit du travail n'est pas
aussi ce qu'il veut et nous ne sommes
pas dupe ce premier chantier ou cette
première brique comme vous l'appeliez
tout à l'heure monsieur le rapporteur
c'est celui de l'affaiblissement des
droits de ceux qui ont déjà le moins
c'est l'illusion d'un nouveau départ et
surtout l'aveu d'un échec celui de votre
précédent très forme qui a déjà impacté
1,15 millions d'allocataires dont la
location a été réduite de 155 euros par
mois en moyenne sans pour autant
oui mais vous prétendez encore faire le
plein emploi les petits salaires les
contrats chez les intermittents d'emploi
les raisons du non recours nous avons eu
tenter de vous rappeler à votre bon
souvenir les raisons de la mauvaise
situation du marché de l'emploi mais
vous les avez sciemment ignoré Pauline
qui travaillait dans la restauration a
vu ces droits baissés de 318 euros par
mois Jean-Paul qui était agent
d'entretien dans les collectivités a vu
sa rémunération baissait de 400 euros
par mois Sandra intérimaire dans le BTP
180 euros ça c'est la réalité de ce que
vous avez fait donc votre trompe l'oeil
mal exécuté voudrait nous faire croire
que cette réforme nous amènera le pleine
emploi mais la réalité c'est qu'il
s'agit surtout de faire des économies
substantielles 6 à 8 milliards d'euros
selon la CFE CGC sur le récit le régime
de l'inédits sans faire baisser le
chômage derrière ce trompe l'oeil vous
ne cherchez finalement qu'à faire payer
au chômeur le coût du mauvais
fonctionnement du marché du travail
plutôt qu'à les en protéger
vous remettez en cause et on a eu
l'occasion de le dire dans les débats la
notion même du régime de l'assurance
chômage un système de trois acquis une
protection collective pour lesquelles
les individus cotisent il ne faudrait
pas l'oublier en préférant faire peser
le risque sur chaque individu
la force de votre employeur en tout cas
réside dans sa vie coloration parce
qu'après votre période votre période
rose monsieur le ministre la période
bleue est désormais pleinement engagée
c'est en tout cas ce que vous avez
cherché à démontrer à la fois dans nos
débats à l'Assemblée nationale mais
c'est aussi ce qui lustre la commission
mixte paritaire qui démontre l'alliance
objective de votre majorité avec les
héritiers du sarkozyme que vous
compartiez pourtant en 2008 et mon
collègue Lucas le rappelait tout à
l'heure en excluant de l'assurance
chômage les titulaires d'un CDD ou d'un
contrat d'intérim refusant un CDI à
temps partiel bien moins payé que leur
enchaîne leur ancien job en faisant de
la cause des tensions sur le marché du
travail les abandons de poste vous avez
repris les techniques picturales de la
droite dur mais Monsieur le Ministre un
bon artiste pour être maître en illusion
doit d'abord s'appuyer sur une analyse
exigeante du réel or vous avez oublié de
lire les rapports de votre propre
administration quand ils existaient et
pour le reste vous avez donc cédé aux
sirènes de la droite dont les
affirmations ne reposaient sur rien
d'autre que des rumeurs mal fondées et
en aucun cas sur des études
scientifiques dans la startup nation on
ne connaît visiblement pas le
harcèlement au travail les burn out le
refus des employeurs de conclure des
ruptures conventionnelles vous avez
continué le réel que vous nous avez
contraints des chiffres à l'aveugle qui
peut penser sérieusement que l'on
préfère rester sans emploi plutôt que de
travailler alors que les freins à
l'emploi sont eux bien connus et je vous
renvoie au rapport de la DARES trop
faible rémunération difficulté de
mobilité de garde d'enfant formation
insuffisante on l'a dit mince des
maintes fois pourtant une autre
assurance chômage était possible d'un
système universel par exemple un système
permettant de réaffirmer la solidarité
du pays pour revenir à un emploi de
qualité justement rémunéré ce système
c'était le système paritaire que vous
détruisez brique par brique le tableau
que vous chercheriez à présenter comme
idyllique finalement ne masque
grossièrement la reproduction des
inégalités le renforcement de la
précarisation de nos concitoyens de nos
concitoyens votre refus de la
négociation sociale et donc la fin de 64
ans de paritarisme les personnes privées
d'emploi continueront de se heurter dans
le mur que vous avez hérissé derrière le
paravent de votre discours illusoire
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
socialiste faudra contre ce texte et
saisira le Conseil constitutionnel je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté pour
5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mais
mes chers collègues c'est une ambition
forte de la majorité présidentielle que
nous partageons de préserver l'avenir de
notre précieux modèle d'assurance
chômage qui permet à chacune et à chacun
d'être égaux face aux fluctuations
économiques sociales et aux face aux
aléas de la vie le contexte dans lequel
nous évoluions et singulier nous l'avons
évoqué longuement lors des débats les
difficultés de recrutement coexistent
avec un chômage trop élevé alors même
que les transformations de l'économie
offrent de nouvelles perspectives et
création d'emplois c'est pourquoi ce
projet s'inscrit dans l'objectif
d'atteindre le plein emploi d'une part
mais aussi la refondation de notre
système d'assurance chômage d'autre part
trouver un système plus juste et plus
protecteur pour les travailleurs
équilibrés dans ces contes c'est la
boussole du groupe horizon mes chers
collègues je pense que nous pouvons nous
féliciter de ce texte mais aussi des
travaux qui depuis septembre on mené
jusqu'à cet équilibre de la commission
mix paritaire et devant cette belle
illustration d'un parlementarisme
constructif on comprend l'extrême
agacement de ceux qui finalement ont
fait de la caricature de la posture et
même de l'outrance l'essentiel de leur
engagement nous pouvons nous féliciter
mais nous pouvons surtout être fiers
quelle belle image du Parlement d'un
parlement qui s'écoute d'un parlement
qui construit d'un parlement qui
effectivement trouve des compromis et le
compromis en politique ça n'est pas un
vilain mot c'est au contraire une
attitude constructive qui permet pour le
bénéfice de l'intelligence de l'intérêt
général c'est à dire des Français
d'avancer sur des sujets aussi complexes
que cela je tiens à remercier et à
saluer les rapporteurs d'abord notre
collègue Marc Ferracci et nos deux
collègues du Sénat Frédéric puissat et
Olivier Hainaut pour leurs travaux sur
ce texte ainsi que vous monsieur le
ministre vous madame la ministre mais
vos équipes aussi pour l'écoute que dont
vous avez fait preuve l'un et l'autre
à l'Assemblée nationale nous avons pu
aller au bout de l'examen de ce projet
de loi en commission vous en souvenez
chers collègues pour ceux qui siègent
mais aussi ici dans cette dans cette
émission au Sénat ça a été rappelé les
débats ont été nourris et les
propositions pour améliorer ce texte ont
été riches aussi enfin la commission
mixparitaire qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière a permis de trouver un texte
équilibré qui reprennent les
dispositions issues des deux chambres
faisant aussi la démonstration de la
force positive du Vicat mérisme nous
pouvons également nous féliciter des
avancées que porte ce texte d'une part
les mesures d'urgence de pérennisation
des règles de l'assurance chômage
assureront à continuer de fonctionnement
notre système cela a été dit c'est
nécessaire de le rappeler et le temps de
la concertation et du dialogue
nécessaire avec les partenaires sociaux
a maintenant débuté va maintenant
débuter il a débuté il va se poursuivre
dans les prochaines semaines le texte
issu de la commission mix paritaire
garantit le plus une réforme de la
gouvernance autour d'un document
d'orientation et affirme le principe de
contrat cyclicité défendu par la
majorité lors des débats d'autre part
ce texte entame et il faut le souligner
la réforme de la validation des acquises
expériences ambition largement partagée
et depuis des années sur les bancs de
cette assemblée du Sénat et ainsi nous
posons les premiers jalons d'un service
public de la VAE autour de ma future
groupement d'intérêt public
au nom du groupe horizon et à parenté
nous nous félicitons évidemment des
dispositions issues des propositions que
nous avions faites lors des débats et
qui ont été retenus dans le texte et
retravaillés par les sénateurs pour
certaines d'entre elles je pense
notamment à l'introduction de la
présomption d'abandon de poste au refus
de deux CDI après plusieurs CDD
proposition travail avec mon collègue
François Gernigon que je salue et enfin
l'expérimentation de CDT de multi
remplacement qui figurent toutes trois
dans le texte toutes ces avancées
permissent par ce travail commun sont à
mettre au regard de l'ensemble des
réformes en cours et à venir notamment
France travail ou la réforme de la voie
professionnelle qui fonctionne dans un
tout cohérent et doit permettre de faire
du travail le cœur de notre système
économique et aussi de protection
sociale oui à la société du travail non
à la société de la paresse au-delà du
bruit et de la recherche de chaos c'est
là une autre des différences entre ceux
qui finalement voteront ce texte et ceux
qui dans une forme de collusion des
extrêmes s'opposeront avec d'ailleurs
des arguments qui sont proches les uns
des autres
proposerons à ce texte nous voterons
nous le groupe horizon avec fierté ce
pour ce texte
issu de la CMP dont nous sommes fiers
d'avoir pu accompagner la construction
merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame marie-charlotte-garin pour le
groupe écologiste lups et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave
madame la Présidente Monsieur et Madame
les ministres madame la Présidente de
commission chers collègues nous sommes
réunis aujourd'hui pour entériner votre
réforme de l'assurance chômage tel que
négocier avec le Sénat après le premier
texte adopté en 2018 le plan se déroule
semble-t-il comme prévu étape une
remplacez le financement par la
cotisation par un financement par
l'impôt étape 2 surveiller les chômeurs
et les forcer à accepter n'importe quel
travail dans n'importe quelle condition
étape 3 un taux de chômage réduit un
salariat à Provis appauvri et des
pauvres invisibilisés dans les
statistiques comme d'habitude et cela ne
surprend déjà plus personne la majorité
présidentielle a choisi de négocier avec
la droite sénatoriale main dans la main
vers toujours plus de précarisation et
de stigmatisation pour les chômeurs
lors de la réunion entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée en à peine une heure c'est
dire à quel point les droites se
retrouvent sur leur vision du travail
plusieurs changements ont été actés
venant aggraver une réforme dont nous
contestions déjà fortement la méthode
l'objectif et les moyens sur le fond une
concession de taille et en pratique
difficilement réalisable a été faite à
la droite désormais de refus en un an
d'un CDI après un CDD ou un contrat
d'intérim sur le même poste le même lieu
et au moins la même rémunération
entraîneront la perte de l'indemnisation
chômage cette mesure injuste n'est pas
en phase avec la réalité d'un bon nombre
de français et de françaises parce
qu'ils sont nombreux et nombreuses à
enchaîner les petits boulots en CDD les
jobs alimentaires en attendant de
trouver ou de retrouver un emploi adapté
à leur qualification ou à leurs envies
parce que sous couvert d'efficacité du
marché vous sacrifiez sur l'hostelle du
sacro-saint pleine emploi la question du
sens dans le travail et vous faites le
choix d'ignorer une société qui se
transforme vous faites le choix
d'ignorer des millions de Français et de
françaises qui veulent s'épanouir dans
leur travail plutôt que se tuer à la
tâche
les sénateurs ont également souhaité
conserver la mesure visant à assimiler
un abandon de poste à une démission et
c'est une collègue de la majorité qui
nous disait le mois dernier que il n'est
pas normal que celui qui abandonne un
poste soit mieux protégé que celui qui a
l'honnêteté de démissionner mais
pourquoi opposer les deux ne
comprenez-vous pas qu'il existe des cas
d'abandon de postes nécessaires lorsque
les salariés n'ont plus le choix en
opposant les deux vous jouez la carte de
la caricature du salarié fainéant qui
abandonne son poste et vous oubliez que
le droit est déjà très clair en la
matière
jusqu'à présent l'abandon de poste c'est
à dire l'absence de manière prolongée ou
répétée du salarié entraîner une
procédure disciplinaire pouvant aboutir
à plusieurs mesures soit une sanction
disciplinaire soit un licenciement pour
causes réelles et sérieuse de nos droits
aux indemnités de licenciement ou alors
un licenciement pour faute grave sans
indemnité de licenciement et finalement
avec cette mesure vous venez affaiblir
encore un peu plus les possibilités de
négociation pour les salariés en fait
cette réforme elle participe à véhiculer
les pires clichés sur les chômeurs alors
je vais me permettre de prendre un
instant pour rappeler quelques vérités
ce sont 7 chômeurs qui sont indemnisés
sur 10 qui reçoivent une allocation
durant moins d'un an près de la moitié
des bénéficiaires de l'allocation
chômage travail en parallèle même
quelques heures par mois quand on parle
de la générosité des allocations qui
n'inciteraient pas les demandeurs
d'emploi à reprendre un travail et bah
les chiffres ils nous disent encore une
toute autre une toute autre histoire en
moyenne les personnes in indemnisé
perçoivent une allocation de 960 euros
net par mois soit un montant qui est
inférieur au seuil de pauvreté ce sont
38% des chômeurs aujourd'hui en France
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et
vous l'imaginez bien les femmes sont
encore plus impactées par cette
précarité
la DARES a aussi révélé dans un rapport
début octobre donc vous vous souvenez ce
fameux rapport qui avait deux ans de
retard qu'on a reçu pile au début de
l'examen et bien ce rapport il nous a
appris que 25 à 42% des personnes
éligibles ne recourt pas à l'assurance
chômage donc c'est dire que quasiment
une personne sur trois qui pourrait être
indemnisée n'en fait même pas la demande
enfin toutes les études concordent les
difficultés de recrutement c'est souvent
par les conditions de travail et pas par
une éventuelle confortable indemnisation
chômage qui donnerait envie d'y rester
et c'est là que j'ai envie de vous dire
que vous vous trompez de cible il vous
faut restructurer les grandes filières
pour la bifurcation écologique il vous
faut investir dans la formation et il
vous faut revaloriser les salaires
si l'assurance chômage vous permet de
refuser un emploi c'est précisément
parce qu'elle joue son rôle en vous
permettant d'aller vers un emploi qui
vous convient et puisque c'est la
dernière expression que nous aurons ici
sur ce texte rappelons le encore une
fois le chômage ça n'est pas un levier
qu'on actionne à sa guise selon la
situation économique dans l'espoir
d'atteindre le plein emploi le chômage
c'est un droit et les Français et les
Françaises cotisent pour en bénéficier
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
écologiste de votre a contre ce texte
économiquement absurde et socialement
injuste je vous remercie merci madame la
députée la parole est à me suivre
Yannick Money pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine nupet et pour
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
en première lecture nous avions dit avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues du groupe
GDR notre refus de voir un tel projet de
loi promulgué non pas parce que nous
pensons qu'aucune réflexion et qu'aucune
réforme n'est nécessaire sur le sujet de
l'assurance chômage de l'accès à
l'emploi et de l'accès à la formation
bien au contraire mais pas comme vous le
concevez regardez en face les premiers
résultats de votre précédent réforme
toujours en vigueur les chiffres du
chômage ne baisse pas selon les
dernières données de la DARES le nombre
de travailleurs en activité réduites qui
alternent ou cumulent emploi précaire et
chômage ne cesse de croître
5,5% sur le troisième trimestre 2022
sur la même période seul 45,5% des
personnes inscrites à Pôle Emploi sont
indemnisés
à ces données s'ajoutent celles du
récent rapport sur le non recours au
droit obtenu de haute luttes par mon
collègue Pierre d'arriville selon lequel
jusqu'à 800000 potentiels allocataires
ne sont pas identifiés
c'est ça le premier bilan de votre
dernière réforme vous voyez bien que
réduire drastiquement les droits d'accès
à l'assurance chômage ne favorisent en
rien le retour à un emploi que nous nous
voulons durable stable et de qualité
d'ailleurs c'est certainement là notre
point de divergence puisque vous avez
favorisé l'emploi précaire les
conditions de travail dégradées la
logique des bas salaires et des emplois
déconnectés de la qualification des
salariés ainsi que la paupérisation des
privés d'emplois
ce n'est pas seulement les privés
d'emploi que outrageusement vous
culpabilisez déclasser c'est l'ensemble
du monde du travail que vous malmenez
pour les députés du groupe GDR il
conviendrait de réfléchir à de nouveaux
droits pour l'ensemble des travailleurs
et des privés d'emploi afin de leur
donner la maîtrise et le sens du travail
afin de soutenir la hausse des salaires
qu'il revendique légitimement
malheureusement l'Union des droites
n'est pas de cet avis le texte de loi la
sortie de la CMP aggrave encore les
conditions des privées d'emploi et des
travailleurs désormais un salarié en
contrat précaire qui refusera deux fois
un CDI se verra refuser l'indemnité de
précarité ces droits à la location
chômage avec une telle disposition vous
substituez à la liberté de choix et donc
d'épanouissement au travail celle de
l'emploi contraint pour forcer l'emploi
vous ignorez volontairement les
situations qui peuvent conduire un
salarié à refuser un CDI comme la forte
pénibilité un salaire trop bas une ligne
adéquation avec le projet de vie ou les
situations de souffrance au travail
et puis il y a la méthode votre méthode
brutale de passage en force comme avec
la réforme de l'éveil à eux introduite
par amendement successifs alors qu'un
tel sujet aurait mérité un débat à part
entière fourni documenté avec une étude
d'impact et des auditions mais qui va
désormais vider l'alternance de son sens
c'est une vraie préfiguration de ce qui
nous attend avec la réforme des lycées
professionnels fini le droit à un
enseignement général place à la seule
employabilité le plus tôt et le plus
vite possible pour parachever votre
oeuvre funestre pour le travail vous
inscrivez la fameuse contracite des cité
dans le code du travail mais pourquoi
alors au final nous faire croire que
vous entamez demain une consultation des
partenaires sociaux que reste-t-il à ses
partenaires dont bon nombre vous ont
signifié refusé cette modulation injuste
des conditions d'indemnisation de
l'assurance chômage
monsieur le ministre votre loi c'est la
négation de la valeur travail qui ne
peut subsister sans une considération
renforcée des travailleurs le mépris de
ce gouvernement pour le monde du travail
qu'on dirait conduira inexorablement à
une maltraitance accrue des salariés et
des privés d'emploi
en plus d'être une conception archaïque
du monde de l'emploi cette loi est un
non sens économique on ne relance pas
une économie en appauvrissant le monde
du travail le groupe GDR vendra donc
contre ce texte emblème d'un projet de
société qui ne dit pas son nom mais qui
a un visage une exploitation renforcée
vis-à-vis du monde du travail bien loin
d'une vraie politique de l'emploi je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est un monsieur Paul André
Colombani pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire et
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente Madame et messieurs
les ministres madame monsieur le
rapporteur madame la commission des
affaires sociales madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
nous le disons la philosophie générale
de ce projet de loi est problématique ce
qui avait été présenté comme un texte
d'urgence comme une simply une simple
modification des règles de calcul pour
lutter contre les difficultés de
recrutement s'est avéré en réalité une
remise en cause conséquente de notre
système d'assurance chômage au nom de
l'urgence vous êtes affranchi des règles
du dialogue social sur les questions qui
ont pourtant en relève pleinement
un mauvais signal alors que le
gouvernement avait placé l'écoute et la
concertation au cœur de ce nouveau
quinquennat un mauvais signal alors que
l'échec des négociations de 2019 avaient
déjà amené le gouvernement à conduire
une réforme d'assurance chômage par
décret et ceux contre la vie de tous les
partenaires sociaux il aurait fallu il
aurait fallu tirer les conséquences de
cet échec qui plus est dans une période
marquée par de fortes tensions sociales
notre groupe avait proposé que les
règles actuellement en vigueur puissent
être prorogées à l'identique le temps de
mener de nouvelles négociations de
nouvelles et réelles négociations le
temps aussi de dégraisser un bilan de la
première réforme d'assurance chômage
c'était un minimum
nous regrettons que le gouvernement
persiste un sa volonté de décider seul
par décret des futurs règles
d'indemnisation nous légiférerons à
l'aveugle sans savoir exactement ce que
ce contiendra ce décret
au-delà de la méthode la philosophie du
texte des problématique sur le fond et
ce encore plus après son examen en
commission mixité
les dispositions initiales comme celles
intégrées par les sénateurs repose tout
sur un présupposé non vérifié celui de
croire que les demandeurs d'emploi ne
travaillent pas car ils ne le veulent
pas
c'est ce que sous-entend l’idée de lier
les règles d'indemnisation chômage à la
conjoncture économique c'est aussi elle
qui est à l'origine de la mesure
consistante à priver d'indemnisation des
personnes refusant un CDI après un CDD
ou une mission d'intérim ne voyait pas
de la naïveté d'un autre propos il y a
des abus et certains mais renoncer à
l'essence même de notre système
assurancier à l'une de ses abus serait
disproportionné le droit au chômage
ne reposera ainsi plus seul sur les
seuls cotisations des assurés mais aussi
sur leur futur choix ou sur la
conjoncture économique c'est un vrai
bouleversement qui aurait mérité des
débats et des études d'impact plus
approfondies
finalement ce projet de loi est
problématique car il vise le plein
emploi sans s'intéresser suffisamment à
toutes les causes du chômage il ne
repose il ne pose pas assez la question
des raisons des difficultés de
recrutement des entreprises c'est une
réflexion globale sur l'emploi et sur le
travail qu'il aurait fallu mener un seul
article sur la validation des acides
d'expérience ne suffira pas à épuiser le
débat
posons-nous la question des
rémunérations des conditions de travail
de la pénibilité de la reconnaissance
sociale posons-nous les questions de la
déquation des métiers et donc de la
formation tout au long de la vie
posons-nous la question de
l'accessibilité des postes et donc de la
mobilité de la garde d'enfants toutes
ces questions tous ces freins à l'emploi
sont mis à côté sont mis de côté au
profit d'une seule affirmation qui est
erronée croire que durcit les règles
croient que durcir les règles
d'assurance chômage résoudra les
difficultés de recrutement mes chers
collègues je vous invite à rejoindre
l'hémic en étant un tout petit peu plus
calme pour que nous puissions écouter
l'orateur je vous remercie
nous posons pas les travailleurs à ceux
qui sont privés d'emploi le chômage est
ni une fatalité ni une facilité je ne
veux pas réduire le débat autour d'une
valeur de travail qui serait défendue
par les uns et pour fendu par les autres
nous croyons tous en un travail
émancipateur et intégrateur mais à
condition que ce travail soit digne je
crois que le vrai débat doit avant tout
porter sur la qualité de l'emploi ce que
le projet de loi ne permet pas
notre groupe n'a finalement obtenu
qu'une petite garantie que ces futurs
règles tiennent compte tiennent compte
des spécificités des Outre-mer
confrontaient des taux de chômage bien
plus importants mais avec des
opportunités d'emploi bien moins
nombreuses
c'est bien la preuve que les réalités
territoriales dicte aussi la réalité
économique et que réformer la seule
assurance chômage n'est pas pertinent
surtout pour les plus vulnérables mais
en dépit de cette garantie notre groupe
ne soutiendra pas ce projet de loi je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
alors je vous informe que sur le texte
de la commission mixte paritaire je suis
saisi par le groupe socialiste et
apparenté d'une demande de scrutin
public qui est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale nous en venons
donc la discussion générale est
maintenant close nous en venons au texte
de la commission mixte paritaire
conformément à l'article 113 alinéa 3 du
règlement je vais appeler l'assemblée la
statuée d'abord sur les amendements dont
je suis saisie amendement numéro 2
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
c'est un amendement rédactionnel il
s'agit de préciser que dans le cas d'un
contrat d'intérim c'est bien à
l'entreprise utilisatrice d'informer
Pôle emploi d'un éventuel refus du
salarié de conclure un contrat à durée
indéterminée à l'issue de sa mission
auprès d'elle je remercie avis ministre
favorable je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement avec un avis favorable du
Gouvernement qui est pour
quai contre il n'est pas il est adopté
pardon le numéro 3 monsieur Ferrette
monsieur rapporteur
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre favorable je vais mettre au
bois cet amendement du rapporteur avec
un ami favorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
il est adopté alors je vous propose
d'attendre une ou deux minutes le temps
que les 5 minutes soit écoulées pour que
nous puissions lancer le scrutin public
mes chers collègues si vous en êtes tous
d'accord je vais lancer le scrutin
public
[Applaudissements]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 356 exprimé
350 majorités 176 pour 210 contre 140
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté